just received publication of the report
into the interview with princess diana
of wales aired on the 20th of november
1995 in the circumstances with which the
journalist martin beshear
was able to obtain that interview
this report carried out by lord dyson
has found
that martin bashir used deceit in order
to conduct and sus and uh get that
interview
and convince princess diana to conduct
that interview
with him he said that
there was deception and let me just find
as i scroll through what is a very very
lengthy report
and behavior that was in breach of the
bbc's guidelines
on straight dealing
he talked about showing princess diana
faked documents faked bank statements by
gaining access to princess diana
in this way mr beshear was able to
persuade her
to agree to give the interview in
serious breach of the 1993 edition of
the bbc's producer
guidelines so considerable
detail in this report very lengthy
report critical
of martin beshear also critical of the
bbc which we'll come to
in response we've had a statement from
the bbc director general tim davey who
says i would like to thank
lord dyson his report into the
circumstances
around the 1995 interview is both
thorough and
comprehensive the bbc accepts lord
dyson's findings in full
although the report states that diana
princess of wales was keen on the idea
of an interview with the bbc
it is clear that the process for
securing the interview fell far short
of what audiences have a right to expect
we're very sorry for this
lord dyson has identified clear failings
well today's bbc has significantly
better processes and procedures
those that existed at the time should
have prevented the interview being
secured
in this way the bbc should have made a
greater effort to get to the bottom of
what happened at the time
and been more transparent about what it
knew while the bbc cannot turn back the
clock
after a quarter of a century we can make
a full
and unconditional apology at the bbc
offers that today let's bring in our
royal correspondent rhiannon mills
so two areas being looked at in this
report rhiannon the conduct of martin
beshear
in securing the interview the methods
that he used
but also the bbc's response and
investigation
into that when those methods may have
come to light
that's right and this is a very complex
and complicated investigation in many
ways because of just how long ago
this all happened it was last year that
many documentary makers marked
25 years since this interview was aired
probably the most
explosive royal interview that was ever
carried out within that interview diana
talked about the fact that there were
three people in that marriage she also
drew questions about whether or not
prince charles would be suitable
as a future king and it was only really
last
november that serious questions started
to
come to mind with a number of people
about exactly how martin beshear had
been able to
secure that interview don't forget at
the time princess diana an
interview with her was probably one of
the most sought after interviews
in the world she was literally being
courted by journalists
right around the world she had some of
the biggest names over in america
here in the uk trying to secure that
interview as she was going through
what people knew was a very difficult
time in her relationship
with the prince of wales and there were
many questions at the time about
why exactly martin beshear had managed
to secure that interview he was
a relatively unknown reporter at the
time and it was actually in november
last year that a series
of documents were released by the bbc
under a freedom of information request
which in some ways brought to light the
fact that martin beshear had
in been using fake documents uh in order
to
coerce and encourage princess diana
to do that interview we know that at the
time she was
incredibly paranoid she was very
vulnerable she was
concerned that people were spying on her
that she was being
looked at by other members of the royal
family that there were conspiracies
against her
and so back in november last year her
brother
lord spencer called for this inquiry by
the bbc to find out exactly who knew
what
within the organization about how he had
secured
that interview now at the time the bbc
said that they would launch
this inquiry which is what we have the
results of today
they asked lord dyson to look in detail
about how exactly that interview was
secured
and also look in detail about whether or
not it had
encouraged princess diana to give that
interview now the report in itself is
127
pages long we know that lord dyson was
able to speak to
as he said all of the key individuals
gave him comprehensive testimony
and that of course will have included
princess
diana's brother uh lord spencer and
today uh yes we are now hearing from
lord dyson that in many ways it fell
short that the investigations that were
carried out within the institution
fell short when it came to looking at
exactly how martin beshear
had secured that interview and i now
think there are many questions this
afternoon
for the bbc about who knew what uh
internally
and why more wasn't done at the time to
reprimand uh martin beshear when it came
to
the practices that he'd used trying to
get that interview with princess diana
yeah rhiannon as you're speaking i'm
just pouring through some more of the
the detail
of the report and it is looking into
that question as to how martin beshear a
relatively
junior reporter at the time uh
managed to secure this interview not a
household name
in 1995 lord dyson concludes but he did
have experience as a television reporter
relatively junior but it is with uh
beyond doubt that he was an effective
and skilled reporter
anyone who watched the interview with
princess diana must have been impressed
by his qualities as an interviewer
quietly spoken and gentle he exuded
charm warmth and above all
empathy